turns out you were right i'm gonna ask
you about free will oh okay
uh you've recently released an episode
of your podcast making sense for those
with a shorter attention span uh
basically summarizing your position on
free will i think it was under an hour
and a half yeah yeah that is
is brief and clear
uh so allow me to summarize the summary
tlgr
and uh maybe you tell me where i'm wrong
so free will is an illusion
and even the experience of free will is
an illusion like we don't even
experience it
what am i am i good in my summary
yeah
this is a
this is a line that's a little hard to
scan for people i i say that it's not
merely that free will
is an illusion
the illusion of free will is an illusion
right like there is no illusion of free
will
and that is a unlike many other
illusions
uh
that's a
a more
fundamental claim it's like it's not
that it's wrong it's it's not even wrong
i mean that's i guess
that was uh i think wolfgang paulie who
derided one of his uh
colleagues or enemies with that uh
um
aspersion about his theory in quantum
mechanics um
it's so there are things that you there
there are genuine illusions there are
things that you do experience
and then you can kind of punch through
that experience or you can't you can't
actually experience you can't you can't
experience them any other way
it's just um
we just know it's not a vertical
experience just take like a visual
illusion there are visual illusions that
you know a lot of these come to me on
twitter these days there's these amazing
visual illusions where like you know
that every figure
in this
gif seems to be moving but nothing in
fact is moving you can just like put a
ruler on your screen and nothing's
moving
um
some of those illusions you can't see
any other way i mean they're just
they're hacking aspects of the visual
system that are just eminently hackable
and you
you know you you have to use a ruler to
to convince yourself that the thing
isn't actually moving
now there are other visual illusions
where you're taken in by it at first but
if you pay more attention you can
actually see that it's not there right
or it's not how it first seemed
like the uh like the necker cube is a
good example of that like the necker
cube is just that schematic of a cube of
a transparent cube which pops out one
way or the other the one one face can
pop out and the other face can pop out
but you can actually just see it as flat
with no pop out which is a more vertical
way of looking at it
so
there are subject there are kind of
inward correlates to this and i would
say that
the um
[Music]
the sense of self a sense of self and
free will are closely related i often
describe them as as two sides of the
same coin but they're not quite the same
in
the their
their spuriousness i mean so the sense
of self is something that
people i think do experience
right it's not a very clear experience
but it's not i wouldn't call the
illusion of self an illusion but the
illusion of free will is an illusion in
that as you pay more attention to your
experience
you begin to see that it's totally
compatible
with an absence of free will you don't i
mean coming back to the place we started
you don't know what you're going to
think next you don't know what you're
going to intend next you don't know
what's going to
just occur to you that you must do next
you don't know you don't know how much
you're going to feel
the behavioral imperative to act on that
thought
if you suddenly feel
oh i don't need to do that that's i can
do that tomorrow
you don't know where that comes from you
didn't know that was going to arise you
didn't know that was going to be
compelling
all of this is compatible with some evil
genius in the next room just typing in
code into your experience just like this
okay let's give him the
uh oh my god i just forgot it was going
to be our anniversary in one week
thought
right give him the cascade of fear
uh give him give him this brilliant idea
for the thing he can buy that's going to
take him no time at all in this this you
know overpowering sense of relief all of
our experiences is compatible with with
the
the script already being written
right it's and i'm not saying the script
is written i'm not saying that fatalism
is
you know is um the right way to look at
this but we just don't have even our
most
deliberate voluntary action where we go
back and forth between two options
you know thinking about the reason for a
and then then reconsidering and going
thinking harder about b and just going
eeny meeny miny moe until the end of the
hour
however laborious you can make it there
is a
utter mystery at your back
finally promoting
the thought or intention
or
ration rationale
that is most compelling and therefore
deliberate
behaviorally
effective uh and
just
i mean
this and this can drive some people a
little crazy so i i usually preface
what i say about free will
with the caveat that if if thinking
about your mind this way makes you feel
terrible well then stop you know get you
get off the ride you know
switch the channel you don't have to go
down this path
but
for me and for for many other people
it's incredibly freeing
just to recognize this about the mind
because
one it re one you realize that you're
cutting through the illusion of the of
the self is immensely freeing for a lot
of reasons that that we can talk about
separately but
losing the sense of free will
does
two things very vividly for me one is it
totally undercuts the basis for the
psychological basis for hatred because
when you when you think about the
experience of hating other people
what that is anchored to
is a feeling that they really are
the true authors of their actions i mean
that someone is doing something
that you find so despicable right let's
say they're you know targeting you
unfairly right they're
maligning you on twitter or they're you
know they're suing you or they're
they're doing something they broke your
car window they did something awful and
now you have a grievance against them
and you're relating to them
very differently emotionally in your own
mind
than you would if a force of nature had
done this right or if it's if it just
been you know a virus or if it had been
a wild animal
or a malfunctioning machine right like
to those things you don't attribute any
kind of freedom of will
and while you you may
suffer the consequences of
catching a virus or being attacked by a
wild animal or having a you know your
car break down or whatever it may
frustrate you
you don't slip into this mode of
hating the agent
in a way that completely
commandeers your your
mind and deranges your life i mean you
just don't i mean there are people who
spend
decades hating other people for
what they did
and it's
it's just pure poison that's a useful
shortcut to compassion and empathy yeah
but the question is
say that this call
what was it the horse of consciousness
let's call it the uh the consciousness
generator black box that we don't
understand
and is it possible that the script
that we're
walking along
that we're playing that's already
written is actually being written in
real time it's almost like you're
driving down a road
and in real time that road is being laid
down yeah and this black box of
consciousness that we don't understand
is the place where this script is being
generated so it's not
it is being generated it didn't always
exist so there's something we don't
understand that's fundamental about the
nature of reality
that generates both consciousness let's
call it maybe the self
i don't know if you want to distinguish
between those yeah i definitely would do
it
you would because there's a bunch of
illusions we're referring to there's the
illusion of free will
there's the illusion of self and there's
the illusion of consciousness you're
saying
i think you said there's no
you're not as willing to say there's an
illusion of consciousness
in fact i would say impossible
impossible
you're a little bit more willing to say
that there's an illusion of self
and you're definitely saying there's an
illusion of free will yes
yes and i'm definitely saying there's an
illusion that a certain kind of self is
an illusion not every we mean many
different things by this notion of self
so maybe i should just differentiate
these things
so consciousness can't be an illusion
because
any illusion
proves its reality as much as any other
vertical perception i mean if you're
hallucinating now
that's just as much of a demonstration
of consciousness
as
really seeing what's a quote actually
there
if you're if you're dreaming and you
don't know it
you that is consciousness
right if you're you can be confused
about literally everything you can't be
confused
about the
the underlying
claim you know whether you make it
linguistically or not but just the the
the
the cognitive
uh assertion
that something seems to be happening
it's the seeming that is is the cash
value of consciousness can i take a tiny
tangent okay so what if
i am
creating consciousness in my mind
to convince you that i'm human so it's a
useful social tool
not
a fundamental property of experience
like of
being a living thing what if it's just
like a social tool to
to
almost like a useful computational trick
to
place myself into reality as we together
communicate about this reality
and another way to ask that because you
said much earlier
you talk negatively about robots as you
often do so let me because um you'll
probably die first when they take over
yeah yeah um no no i'm looking forward
to certain kind of robots i mean i i'm
not
if we can get this right this would be
amazing right but you don't like the
robots that fake consciousness that's
what you you don't like the idea of fake
it till you make it well no i it's not
that i don't like it it's that
i'm worried that we will lose sight of
the problem and the problem has massive
ethical consequences if we cr if we
create robots that really can suffer
yeah that would be a bad thing right and
if if we really are committing a murder
when we recycle them
that would be a bad thing that's how i
know you're not russian why is it a bad
thing that would create robots that can
suffer isn't suffering a fundamental
thing from which like beauty springs
like without suffering do you really
think we would have beautiful things in
this world
okay well that's a that's a tangent on a
tangent okay we'll go there i would love
to go there but let's not go there just
yet all right but you know i do think it
would be if anything is bad
creating hell and populating it with
real minds that really can suffer in
that hell that's you know that's bad you
know that's the the you are
you are worse than than any mass
murderer we can name if you created i
mean this could be in robot form or you
know more likely it would be in
in some similar simulation of a world
where we managed to populate it with
conscious minds so that we know whether
we knew they were conscious or not
and that world is is a state of you know
that's it's unendurable um that would
just it just taking the thesis seriously
that
there's nothing
that mind intelligence and consciousness
ultimately are substrate independent
right it doesn't you don't need a
biological brain to be conscious you
certainly don't need a biological brain
to be intelligent right so
if we just imagine the consciousness at
some point comes along for the ride as
you scale up in intelligence
well then we could find ourselves
creating conscious minds
that are miserable right and that's just
like creating a person who's miserable
right it could be worse than creating a
person who's miserable could be even
more sensitive to suffering cloning them
and
maybe for entertainment watching them
suffer
just like
watching a person for suffer for
entertainment you know
so but but back to your the
your primary question here which is
differentiating differentiating
consciousness and self and free will as
concepts and kind of degrees of
illusoriness
the problem with free will is that
what most people mean by it
and that the
you know and dan this is where dan
dennett is going to get off the ride
here right so like he he doesn't he's
going to disagree with me that i that i
know what most people mean by it but
i have a very uh
keen sense having talked about this
topic for many many years and
people get wrapped around the axle of it
and seeing
seeing in myself what it's like to have
felt
that i was a self that had free will and
then to no longer feel that way right i
mean to know what it's like to actually
disabuse myself of that
sense
cognitively and emotionally
and to recognize what's left what goes
away and what doesn't go away
on the basis of that epiphany
i have a sense that i know what people
think they have in hand when they worry
about whether free will exists
and
it is
the it is the flip side of this feeling
of self it's the flip side of feeling
like you are not merely identical to
experience
you feel like you're having an
experience you feel like you're an agent
that is appropriating an experience
there is a protagonist
in the movie of your life and it is you
it's not just the movie
right it's like the the every like their
sights and sounds and sensations and
thoughts and emotions and this whole
cacophony
of experience a felt experience a felt
experience of embodiment
but there seems to be
a a rider on the horse or a passenger in
the body right people don't feel truly
identical to their bodies down to their
toes
they sort of feel like they have bodies
they feel like they're minds in bodies
and that feels like
a self that feels like me and
again this gets very paradoxical when
you talk about
the experience of of being in
relationship to yourself or talking to
yourself you know giving yourself a pep
talk i mean if you're the one talking
why are you also the one listening like
why do you need the pep talk and why
does it work if you're the one giving
the pep talk right yeah or like or if i
said like where are my keys right if i'm
looking for my keys why do i think the
superfluous thought where are my keys i
know i'm looking for the [ __ ] keys
i'm the one looking who am i telling
that you know that we need now need to
look for the keys right so that duality
is weird but leave that aside there's
the sense
so and this this becomes very vivid when
people try to learn to meditate
you know most people they start by they
start they close their eyes and they're
told to pay attention to an object like
the breath say so you close your eyes
and you pay attention to the breath and
you can feel it at the tip of your nose
or the rising falling of your abdomen
and you're you're paying attention and
you feel something vague there
and then you think i thought why the
breath why am i
why am i paying attention to the breath
what's what's so special about the
breath and then you then you then you
notice you're thinking and you're not
paying attention to the breath anymore
and then you then you realize okay the
practice is okay
i should notice thoughts and then i
should come back to the breath
but
this starting point is the of the
conventional starting point of feeling
like you're an agent very likely in your
head
a locus of consciousness a locus of
attention that can strategically pay
attention to certain parts of experience
like i can focus on the breath and then
i get lost in thought and now i can come
back to the breath and i can open my
eyes and i can i'm over here behind my
face
looking out at a world that's other than
me and there's this kind of subject
object perception
and that is the default starting point
of selfhood of subjectivity
and
married to that is the sense that
i can decide
what to do next right i am i am an agent
who can pay attention to the cup
i can listen to sounds there are certain
things that i can't control certain
things are happening to me and i just
can't control them so for instance
that if someone asks well can you not
hear
a sound right like don't hear the next
sound don't hear anything for a second
or don't hear don't hear i'm you know
i'm snapping my fingers don't hear this
where's your free will you know will i
just stop this from coming in you you
you realize okay wait a minute my my my
abundant freedom does not extend
to something as simple as just being
able to pay attention to something else
than this
okay well so that i'm not that kind of
free agent but at least i can decide
what i'm going to do next and i'm going
to i'm going to pick i'm going to pick
up this water
right
and
there's a feeling of identification
with
the impulse with the intention with the
thought that occurs to you with the with
the feeling of speaking like you know
what am i what am i going to say next
well i'm saying it so here goes
this is me i it feels like i'm the
thinker i'm the i'm
the one who's in control
but all of that is born of not
really paying close attention
to what it's like to be you and and so
this is
this is where meditation comes in or
this is where um again you can get you
can get at this conceptually
you can unravel the notion of free will
just by by
thinking certain certain thoughts
but you can't feel
that it doesn't exist unless you can pay
close attention to how thoughts and
intentions arise so the way to unravel
it conceptually is just to realize okay
i didn't make myself i didn't make my
genes i didn't make my brain i didn't
make the
the environmental influences that
impinged upon this system for the last
54 years
that have produced my brain in precisely
the state it's in right now such and
with all of the
the receptor weightings and densities
and you know it's just
i'm i'm exactly the machine i am right
now through no
fault of of
my own as the experiencing self i get no
credit and i get no blame
for the genetics and the enviro the
environmental influences here and yet
those are the only things that could
contrive
to
to produce my next thought or
impulse or or moment of behavior and if
you were going to add something magical
to that clockwork like an immortal soul
you can also notice that you didn't
produce your soul rightly you can't
account for the fact that you don't have
the soul
of someone
who doesn't like any of the things you
like or wasn't interested in any of the
things you were interested in or you
know or
was a psychopath or was either you had
an iq of 40 or like there's nothing
nothing about that that the person who
believes in us in a soul can claim to
have controlled and yet that is also
totally dispositive of whatever happens
next and but everything you've described
now
maybe you can correct me but it kind of
speaks to the materialistic nature of
the hardware
but even if you add magical
ectoplasm software
you didn't produce that either i i know
but
if we can think about the
actual computation running on the
hardware
and running on the software there's
something you said recently which you
think of uh
culture as an operating system
so if we just
remove ourselves a little bit from the
conception of
human civilization being a collection of
humans and rather us just being a
distributed
uh
computation system on which there's some
kind of operating system running and
then the computation that's running is
the actual thing that generates
the interactions the communications and
maybe even free will the experiences of
all those free will do you ever think of
do you ever try to reframe the world in
that way where it's like
ideas are just using us
thoughts are using
individual nodes in the system
and they're just jumping around and they
also have ability to generate like
experiences so that we can push those
ideas along and basically the main
organisms here are the thoughts not the
humans
yeah but then that erodes the boundary
between
self and world
right so so then there's no self
really a really integrated self to have
any kind of will at all
like if you're just a meme plex i mean
if there's just like if if you're just a
collection of memes yeah and
i mean like we're all kind of like like
currents like eddies in in in this river
of of ideas right so it's like um
and it seems to have structure but
there's no real boundary between that
part of the flow of water and the rest i
mean if our and i would say that much of
our mind answers to this kind of
description i mean so much of our mind
has been
[Music]
it's obviously not self-generated and
it's not it's not going to find it by
looking in the brain it's it it is the
result of
culture largely but also um
uh
[Music]
you know it's it's the genes on one side
and culture on the other m
meeting to
allow for
manifestations of mind that don't that
aren't actually bounded by
the the person in any
clear sense it was just
the example
i often use here but there are so many
others is just the fact that we're
following the rules of english grammar
to whatever degree we are
it's not that we certainly haven't
consciously represented these rules for
ourselves we haven't invented these
rules we haven't i mean there are there
are norms of
language use that we couldn't even
specify because we haven't you know
we're not grammarians we're not we
haven't studied this
we don't even have the right concepts
and yet we're following these rules and
we're noticing
you know we're noticing as you know an
error when we fail to follow these rules
um
and virtually every other cultural norm
is like that i mean these are not things
we've invented you can you can
consciously decide to
to scrutinize them and override them
but
i mean just think of just think of any
social situation where you're with other
people
and you're
behaving in ways that are culturally
appropriate right you're not being you
know you're not being wild animals
together you're following you have some
expectation of how you shake a person's
hand and how you
um
deal with with implements on a table how
you have a meal together obviously this
can change from culture to culture and
and people can be shocked by how
different those things are right we you
know we all have foods we find
disgusting but in some countries dog is
not one of those foods right and yet you
know you and i presumably would be
horrified to be served dog
those are not norms that we're
they are outside of us in some way and
they're yet they're they're felt
very viscerally i mean they're certainly
felt in their violation you know if
you're if you are just imagine you're
you're in
somebody's home
you're eating something that tastes
great to you
and you happen to be in vietnam or
wherever you know you you didn't realize
dog was potentially on the menu and
you find out that you've just eaten
10 bites of what is uh you know really a
cocker spaniel and
you feel this instantaneous urge to
vomit right based on an idea
right like so like you did not
you're not the author of that norm
that get gave you
such a powerful experience of its
violation and i'm sure we can trace the
moment
in your history you know vaguely where
it sort of got in i mean very early on
as kids you you realize you're you're
treating dogs as pets and not as food or
as potential food
but
yeah no it's
but the point you just made
opens us to like we are totally
permeable to a sea of
mind yeah but if we take the metaphor of
the distributed computing systems each
individual node
is
is part of performing a much larger
computation
but nevertheless
is in charge of doing the scheduling of
so
assuming it's linux is doing the
scheduling of processes and it's
constantly alternating them that node is
making those
choices that node sure as hell believes
it has free will
and actually has free will because it's
making those hard choices but the
choices ultimately are part of much
larger computation that it can't control
isn't it possible for that node to still
be that human node
uh is still making the choice well it is
so i'm not saying that
your body
isn't doing really doing things right
and
some of those things can be
conventionally thought of as choices
right so it's like i can i can choose
to reach and it's like
it's not being imposed on me that would
be a different experience like so
there's a
there's an experience of
of all you know there's definitely a
difference between voluntary and
involuntary action
there's uh so we that has to get
conserved by any account of the mind
that jettison's free will you still have
to admit that that
there's a difference between a tremor
that i can't control and
a
a
purposeful motor action that i can
control and i can initiate on demand and
it's associated with intentions
uh and i've it's got efferent
you know motor copy which which is being
which is being predictive so that i can
notice errors you know i have
expectations when i reach for this if my
hand were actually to pass through the
bottle because it's a hologram i would
be surprised right so that shows that i
have a expectation of just what my
grasping behavior is going to be like
even before it happens
whereas with a tremor you don't have the
same kind of
thing going on
that's a distinction we have to make
um so i am yes i'm really the proxy my
intention to move
subject which is in fact can be
subjectively felt really is the
proximate cause of my moving it's not
coming from elsewhere in the universe
i'm not saying that
so in that sense the node is really
deciding to execute you know the the
subroutine
now
but
um
that's not
the feeling
that has given rise to this this
conundrum
of free will right so the the people
feel like
people feel like they the crucial things
that people feel like they could have
done otherwise
right that's the that's the thing that
says when you when you run back the
clock of your life
right you run back the movie of your
life you flip back the few pages in the
novel of your life
they feel that at that at this point
they could behave differently than they
did right so like like but but given you
know even given your distributed
computing example
it's either a determining a fully
deterministic system or it's a
deterministic system that admits of some
random
you know influence in either case
um
that's not the free will people think
they have the p the free will people
think they have is
damn i shouldn't have done that i i just
like i i shouldn't have done that i
could have done otherwise right i should
have done otherwise right like if i like
if you think about something that you
deeply regret doing
right or that you do you hold someone
else responsible for
because they really are the upstream
agent in your mind of what they did
you know that's an awful thing that that
person did and they shouldn't have done
it
there is this illusion and it has to be
an illusion because there's there's no
picture of causation that would make
sense of it
there's this illusion that that if you
arrange the universe exactly the way it
was a moment ago
it could have played out differently
and
the only way it could have played out
differently
is if
there's randomness added to that but
randomness isn't what people feel
would give them free will right if you
tell me that
you know i only reach for the water
bottle this time because somebody's
because there's a random number
generator in there kicking off values
and it finally moved my hand
that's not the feeling of authorship
that's still not control you're still
not making that decision
there's actually i don't know if
you're familiar with cellular automata
it's a really nice visualization of
how simple rules can create
incredible complexity that
it's like really dumb initial conditions
to set simple rules applied and
eventually you watch this thing
and if the rule if the initial
conditions are correct you're going to
have emerge something that to our
perception system looks like organisms
interacting you can construct any kinds
of worlds and they're not actually
interacting
it's not they're not actually even
organisms
and they certainly don't aren't making
decisions so there's like systems you
can create that illustrate this point
the question is
whether there could be some
room for
let's use in the 21st century the term
magic
back to the black box of consciousness
let me ask you it this way if you're
wrong about your intuition about free
will
what and somebody comes along to you and
proves
to you that
you didn't you didn't have the full
picture what would that proof look like
what would uh well that's that's the
problem that's why it's not even an
illusion in my world because
it's for me it's impossible to say
what the universe would have to be like
for free will to be a thing right it's
just it doesn't conceptually map onto
any
notion of causation we have
and
that's unlike any other spurious claim
you might make so like
if you're going to if you're going to
believe in ghosts
right
i understand what that claim could be or
like i you know i don't happen to
believe in ghosts but
if
it's it's not hard for me to specify
what would have to be true for ghosts to
be real
and so it is with a thousand other
things like ghosts right so like okay so
you're telling me that when people die
there's some part of them that is not
reducible at all to their biology that
lifts off them
and goes elsewhere and is actually the
kind of thing they can linger in closets
and in cupboards and
and actually
it's immaterial but by some principle of
physics we don't totally understand it
can make sounds and knock
you know objects and even occasionally
show up so they can be visually beheld
and
it's just
it seems like a miracle but it's just
this is just some spooky noun in the
universe that we don't understand
let's call it a ghost
that's fine i can talk about that all
day the reasons to believe in it the
reasons not to believe in it the way we
would scientifically test for it what
would have to be provable so as to
convince me that ghosts are real
free will isn't like that at all there's
no description
of any concatenation of causes
that precedes my conscious experience
that sounds like what people think they
have when they think they could have
done otherwise and that they really that
they the conscious agent
is really in charge
right like if you don't know what you're
going to think next
right and you can't help but think it
take those two
premises on board you don't know what
it's going to be you can't stop it
from coming
and until you actually
know how to meditate
you can't
stop yourself from
fully living out its behavioral or
emotional consequences right like you
have no you once you mindfulness you
know
arguably gives you a
another degree of freedom here it
doesn't give you free will but it gives
you some other game to play with respect
to the the the emotional and behavioral
imperatives of thoughts
but
short of ev
short of that i mean the reason why
mindfulness doesn't give you free will
is because you can't you know you can't
account for why in one moment
mindfulness arises and and in other
moments it doesn't right
but um but a pro a different process is
initiated once you can can
practice in that way well if i could
push back for a second by the way i just
had this thought bubble come popping up
all the time of just two recent chimps
arguing about the nature of
consciousness
it's kind of hilarious so on that thread
right you know
if we're even before einstein let's say
before einstein we were to conceive
about traveling from point a to point b
say some point in the future
we are able to realize through
engineering a way
which is supposed is consistent with
einstein's theory that you can have
wormholes you can travel from one point
to another
faster than the speed of light
and that would i think completely change
our conception what it means to travel
in the physical space
and that
like completely transform our ability
you talk about causality but here let's
just focus on
what it means to travel through physical
space don't you think it's possible that
there will be
inventions
or leaps in understanding about reality
that will allow us to see free will as
actually
like
us humans somehow may be linked to this
idea of consciousness are actually able
to be authors of our actions
it is a it's a non-starter for me
conceptually
it's a little bit like saying
could there be some breakthrough that
will cause us to realize that
circles are really square
or the circles are not really round
right no a circle is what we mean by a
perfectly round form right like it's
it's it's
it's not it's not on the table to be
revised and
so i would say the same thing about
consciousness so it's just like saying
is there some breakthrough
that would get us to realize that
consciousness is really an illusion i'm
saying no because what the experience of
an illusion is as much a demonstration
of what i'm calling consciousness as
anything else right like that that is
consciousness
um with free will
it's a similar problem it's like um
again it comes down to a picture of
causality and there's just there's no
there's no other picture on offer
and what's more
i know i know what it's like on the
experiential side
to lose the thing
to which it is clearly anchored right
like the feel like
it doesn't feel and this is and this is
the question that almost nobody has
people who are debating me on on the
topic of free will
i i'm you know at 15 minute intervals
i'm making a claim that i don't feel
this thing and they
are never become interested in
well what's that like like okay so
you're actually saying you don't you
this this thing isn't you know
isn't true for you empirically it's not
just because most people who
who don't believe in free will
philosophically
also believe that we're condemned to
experience it like they you just you
can't live without this feeling so
so you're actually saying you're able to
experience the absence of
the illusion of free will yes yes for
are we talking about
whenever whenever minutes at a time
or
um
is this to require a lot of work and
meditation are you literally able to
load that into your mind and like play
that right now right now just in this
conversation so it's not it's not
absolutely continuous
but
it's whenever i pay attention
it's like it's the same and i would say
the same thing for the
the illusoriness of the self in the sen
and again we we haven't talked about
this so can you still have the self and
not have the free will yeah mine at the
same time do they go at the same time
this is the same yeah it's the same
thing
they're always holding hands when they
walk out the door there really are two
sides of the same coin okay but it's
just it comes down to what it's like
to try to get to the end of this
sentence or what it's like to to finally
decide that it's been long enough and
now i need another sip of water right if
i'm paying attention now if i'm not
paying attention
i'm probably i'm captured by some other
thought and that feels a certain way
right and so that's not it's not it's
not vivid but if i try to make vivid
this experience of just okay
i'm finally going to experience free
will i'm going to notice my free will
right like it's got to be here
everyone's talking about it where is it
i'm going to pay attention to it i'm
going to look for it and i'm going to
i'm going to create a circumstance
that is is where it has to be most
robust right i'm not rushed to make this
decision
i'm not it's not a reflex
i'm not under pressure i'm going to take
as long as i want i'm going to decide
it's not trivial like so it's not just
like reaching with my left hand to reach
with my right hand people don't like
those examples for some reason let's
make a big decision like
where should
you know
what should my next podcast be on right
who do i invite on the next podcast
what is it like to make that decision
when i pay attention
there is no evidence of free will
anywhere in sight it's like it doesn't
feel like it feels profoundly mysterious
to be to be going back between two
people you know like is it going to be
person a or person b
i've got all my reasons for a and all my
reasons why not and all my reasons for
be and that there's some math going on
there that i that i'm not not even privy
to
where certain concerns are trumping
others
and at a certain point i just decide
and
yes you can say i'm the node in the
network that has made that decision
absolutely i'm not saying it's being
piped to me from elsewhere
but the feeling of what it's like to
make that decision
is
totally without
a sense a real sense of
agency because because something
simply emerges it's literally it's
literally as tenuous as
what's the next sound i'm going to hear
right or what's a what's the next
thought
that's going to appear and it just
something just appears
you know and and if something appears to
cancel that something like if i say
i'm going to invite her
and then i'm about to send the email and
i think oh no no i can't i can't do that
there was a thing in the that new york
article i read that i got to talk to
this guy right
that pivot at the last second you can
make it as as
muscular as you want
it always just comes out of the darkness
it's always mysterious
so right when you try to pin it down you
really can't ever find that free will
it's the the the
the the if you construct an experiment
for yourself and you're trying to really
find that moment when you're actually
making that controlled author decision
it's it's uh and we're still we're still
we know at this point that if we were
scanning your brain
in
some ex you know podcast guest choosing
experiment right
we know at this point we would be privy
to who you're going to pick before you
are you the conscious agent if we could
again this is
operationally a little hard to conduct
but
there's enough data now to know that
something very much like this cartoon is
in fact true
um and will ultimately be undeniable for
people
um they'll be able to do it on
themselves with their you know some app
um
if you're deciding
what to you know where to go for dinner
or who to have on your podcast or
ultimately you know who to marry right
or what what city to move to right like
you you can make it as big or as small a
decision as you want
we could be scanning your brain in real
time and
at a point where you still think you're
uncommitted
we would be able to say with
arbitrary accuracy
all right lex is he's moving to austin
right i didn't choose that yeah he was
true it was it was going to be austin it
was going to be miami he got he's
catching one of these two waves
but it's going to be austin and at a
point where you subjectively
if we if we could ask you you would say
oh no i'm still i'm still working over
here
i'm still thinking still choosing i'm
still considering my options
and you've spoken to this
in you thinking about other stuff in the
world it's been very useful
to uh to step away from this illusion of
free will and you argue that it's
probably makes a better world because
you can be compassionate and empathetic
towards others and towards oneself
i mean
radically toward others in that
literally hate makes no sense anymore i
mean there are certain things you can
really be worried about really want to
oppose really i mean i'm not saying
you'd never have to kill another person
like i mean self-defense is still a
thing right
but the idea
that you're ever
confronting anything other than a force
of nature in the end
goes out the window right or what does
go out the window when you really pay
attention i'm not i'm not saying that
this would be easy
to under to grok if
you know
you know someone kills a member of your
family i'm not saying you can just
listen to my 90 minutes on free will and
then you should be able to see that
person as identical to a grizzly bear or
a or a virus
because it's so i mean we are so
evolved
to
uh
deal with one another as
as fellow primates and as agents
but it's um
yeah when you're talking about the
possibility of
you know christian
you know truly christian forgiveness
right it's just like
uh that as as testified to by you know
various um
uh
saints of that flavor over the over the
the millennia
yeah that is that
the doorway to that is to recognize that
no one really at bottom made themselves
right and and therefore everyone what
we're seeing really
are differences in luck
in the world we're seeing people who are
very very lucky
to have had good parents and good genes
and to be in good societies and good
opportunities and to be intelligent and
to be you know not sociopathic like
it's
none of it is on them they're just
reaping one lot the the fruits of one
lottery
after another and then showing up in the
world on that basis
um
and then so it is with
you know every malevolent [ __ ] out
there right he he or she didn't make
themselves
even if that weren't
possible
the utility for for self-compassion is
also enormous because it's
when you just look at what it's like to
regret
something or to feel shame about
something or feel deep embarrassment
about i mean these states of mind are
some of the most
deranging experiences anyone has and and
they're reactive the the kind of the the
indelible reaction
to them
you know the memory of the thing you
said the you know the memory of the
wedding toast you gave 20 years ago that
was just mortifying right
the fact that that can still make you
hate yourself right and like like that
psychologically that is a knot
that can be untied
right for yourself sam yeah yeah clearly
you're not you gave a great great toast
it was my toast that mortified no no
that's not what i was referring to i i
i i'm deeply appreciative
in the same way that you're referring to
of every moment i'm alive but i'm also
powered by self-hate often
like
several things in this conversation
already that i've spoken
i'll be thinking about like that was the
dumbest thing you're sitting in front of
sam harris he said that
so like that but that
somehow creates a richer experience for
me like i've actually come to accept
that as a nice feature of however my
brain was built i don't think i want to
let go of that well the thing you i
think the thing you want to let go of is
uh
the suffering associated with it so like
so for me so so
mr psychologically and ethically all of
this is very interesting
so i don't think we ever we should ever
get rid of things like anger right so
like hatred is hatred is divorceable
from anger
in the sense that
hatred is this enduring state
where
you know whether you're hating somebody
else or hating yourself
it is just it is toxic
and durable and ultimately useless right
like it becomes it becomes self
nullifying right like you become less
capable as a person to solve any of your
problems it's not it's not instrumental
in solving the problem that is that is
is occasionally in all this hatred
and anger
for the most part isn't either except as
a signal of salience that there's a
problem right so if somebody does
something that makes me angry
that just promotes this situation to to
conscious uh conscious attention in a
way that is
stronger than my not really caring about
it right and there are things that i
think should make us angry in the world
and there the there's the behavior of
other people that should make us angry
because we should respond to it and so
it is with yourself if i do something
you know as a parent if i do something
stupid that harms one of my daughters
right
my belief my experience of myself and my
beliefs about free will
closed the door to my saying well i
should have done otherwise in the sense
that if i could go back in time i would
have actually effectively done otherwise
no i would do given the same causes and
conditions i would do that thing a
trillion times in a row right
but
you know
regret and
feeling bad about an outcome
are still important to capacities
because like yeah you're like i i
desperately want my daughters to be
happy and healthy so if i if i've done
something you know if i if i crash the
car when they're in the car and they get
injured right because and i'm i do it
because i was trying to change the song
on my playlist or you know something
stupid
i'm going to feel like a total [ __ ]
how long do how long do i stew in that
feeling of regret right and
like
what utility is there to extract out of
this error signal and then what do i do
we're always faced
with the question of what to do next
right and and how to best do that thing
that necessary thing next
and
how much well-being can we experience
while doing it like how much how
miserable do you need to be
to solve your problems in life
and to solve the problems of to help
solve the problems of people closest to
you you know how how miserable do you
need to be to get through your to-do
list today
ultimately
i think
you can be
deeply happy
going through all of it right and not
and and even navigating moments that are
scary and you know
really destabilizing to ordinary people
and
um
i mean i think you know again
i'm i'm always up
kind of at the edge of my own capacities
here and there all kinds of things that
stress me out and worry me and i'm
especially something if it's you're
going to tell me it's something with you
know the health of one of my
kids you know it's very hard for me like
it's very hard for me to to be truly
equanimous around that
but equanimity is so useful
the moment you're in in response mode
right because i mean the the ordinary
experience
for me
of
responding to what seems like a medical
emergency for one of my kids
is to be
obviously super
energized by concern to respond to that
emergency
but then once i'm responding
all of my fear and agitation and worry
and oh my god what if this is really
something terrible
but
finding any of those thoughts compelling
all that only diminishes my capacity as
a father
to be good company while we navigate
this really turbulent
passage you know as you're saying this
actually one guy comes to mind which is
elon musk one of the really
impressive things to me was to observe
how many dramatic things he has to deal
with throughout the day
at work but also if you look through his
life
family too
and how he's very much actually
as you're describing basically a
practitioner of this way of thought
which is
you're not in control
you're basically responding no matter
how traumatic the event and there's no
reason to sort of linger on the
well yeah i think the negative feelings
are on that well so i mean but he's in a
very specific
situation which is which is unlike
normal life
you know even his normal life but normal
life for for most people because when
you just think of like you know he's
running so many businesses and he's he's
they're very they're not they're
non-highly non-standard businesses so
what he's seen is
everything that gets to him is some kind
of emergency like it wouldn't be getting
to him if it needs his attention
there's a fire somewhere so exactly so
he's constantly responding to fires that
have to be put out
so there's no default expectation that
there shouldn't be a fire right but in
our normal lives we live most of most of
us who are lucky right not everyone
obviously on earth but most of us who
are at some kind of cruising altitude
in terms of our lives
where we're reasonably healthy and life
is reasonably orderly and the political
apparatus around us is reasonably
functionable
functional
functionable so i said functional for
the first time in my life through no
free will of my own see like i notice
those errors and they do not feel like
like like agency
and nor does nor does the success of an
utterance feel like agency
he
when you're when you're looking at
normal human life right where you're
you're just trying to be happy and
healthy and get your work done
there's this default expectation that
there shouldn't be fires people
shouldn't be getting sick or injured you
know the the we shouldn't be losing vast
amounts of our resources we should like
so
when something really start like that
happens
um
people don't have a people don't have
that muscle that they've like i've been
responding to emergency emergencies all
day long
you know
seven days a week
in business mode and so i have a very
thick skin this is just another one what
was i i'm not expecting anything else
when i wake up in the morning
no we have this default sense that
i mean honestly most of us have the
default sense that we
aren't going to die right or that we
should like maybe we're not going to die
right like death denial
really is a thing you know we're we
we're
because and you can see it
just like i can see
when i reach for this bottle
that i was expecting it to be solid
because when it isn't solid when it's a
hologram and i just my fist closes on
itself
i'm damn surprised people are damn
surprised to find out that they're going
to die to find out that they're sick to
find out that someone that they love
has died or is going to die so it's like
the the fact that we are
surprised by any of that
shows us that we're we're living at a uh
we're living in a mode
that is um
you know we
we're perpetually diverting ourselves
from some facts that should be obvious
right and that
and the more the more salient we can
make them uh you know the more
i mean in the case of death it's a
matter of of being able to get one's
priorities straight i mean the moment
again this is hard for everybody even
those who are really in the business of
paying attention to it but
the moment you realize that every
circumstance is finite right you've got
a certain number of you know you've got
whatever whatever it is 8 000 days left
in a normal span of life
and 8 000 is a sounds like a big number
it's not that big a number right so it's
just like and then you then you can
decide
how you want to go through life uh and
how you want to experience each one of
those days
and so i was back to where our jumping
off point
i would argue that you don't want to
feel
self-hatred ever
i i i would argue that you don't want to
really
uh
really grasp on to any of those moments
where you where you
are take or internalizing the fact that
you just made an error you embarrassed
yourself that something didn't go the
way you wanted it to i think you wanted
you want to treat all of those moments
very very lightly you want to extract
the the actionable information
it's something to learn oh you know i i
learned that
when i when i prepare in a certain way
it works better than i when i prepare in
some other way or don't prepare right
like so like yes
lesson learned you know and and do that
differently
but
um
yeah i mean so many so many so many of
us have spent so much
time with
a very uh
dysfunctional and hostile and even
hateful inner voice
governing a lot of our self-talk and a
lot of just just our default way of
being with ourselves i mean the privacy
of our own minds
we're in the company of of a real jerk a
lot of the time and
um
and that that can't help but affect i
mean forget about just your your own
sense of well-being it can't help
but limit what you're capable of in the
world with other people i'll have to
really think about that i just take
pride that my jerk my inner voice jerk
is much less of a jerk than like
somebody like david goggins who's just
like screaming in his ear constantly so
my i just i have a relativist kind of
perspective that it's not as bad as that
at least well having a sense of humor
also helps you know it's just like it's
not the stakes are
never quite what you think they are and
even when they are i mean just the
difference between
see being able to see the comedy of it
rather than
because because again there's this
sort of dark star of self-absorption
that pulls everything into it right and
it's like if if that that's the that's
the algorithm that's the algorithm you
don't want to run so it's like you just
want you just want things to be good so
like just push push the concern
out there like like the like the
not have the collapse of oh my god what
does this say about me it's just like
let's what does this say about
how do we make this meal that we're all
having together as
as uh
as fun as po and as useful as possible
and you're saying in terms of propulsion
systems you recommend humor as a good
spaceship to escape the gravitational
field of the
of that darkness well that certainly
helps yeah
you